how are you Howard back I'm doing well
rich how are you I'm better for talking
to you make heads or tails of that
Warriors Timberwolves trade very rare
that a 14 and 15 seed of a conference
make a blockbuster but it appears to be
the clubhouse leader right now the
bigger eyebrow raiser Howard right yeah
I mean on the Minnesota side of it
there's no surprise at all we've known
that they were in a hot pursuit of
DeAngelo Russell for some time wanted to
sign him last summer before he ended up
going to the Warriors in that sign and
trade deal and DeAngelo Russell is tight
with karl-anthony towns he feels the
need he you know allows Griffin roses
and his his crew the new front office to
put a different kind of stamp on this
team that has just been kind of you know
wandering the desert for the last few
years and couldn't quite get traction I
have no issues on their side of it on
the warrior side of it I just have
curiosity it's you DeAngelo Russell
signing was always a signing of
convenience you're losing car durant
he's agreed to do a sign-and-trade you
do a dual sign and trade and you get
DeAngelo Russell now you don't lose
Durant for nothing he's a placeholder he
could play with curry or whatever
however you want to see hit DeAngelo
Russell you could have seen him as a
short-term long-term whatever I do think
it was inevitable they were going to
trade him I do think it was inevitable
you would see it may move to try to
maximize his value in another deal
whether they got the best value is going
to be the question going forward because
Andrew Wiggins obviously was number one
number one picked for a reason but he's
been a very frustrating player a lot of
talent a lot of potential still four or
five years into his career but it's it's
not clear where we know what his
ultimate ceiling will be and I think
this is probably the Warriors of having
a vote of confidence in themselves we
will develop him better we'll put them
in a better context and by the way
there's a huge difference between being
Andrew Wiggins next to another young
player like towns trying to prop up a
franchise that's been you know in a bad
way for a long time versus Andrew
Wiggins going to team that's won three
championships with three Hall of Famers
sitting there
are waiting for you to play with them
and play a role not have to be the guy
who's carrying a franchise and has all
of that on his shoulders so you might
see a very different Wiggins in that
context so I guess if I had told you
when the Russell signing happened that
essentially the Warriors in losing
Durant as we assumed they might again
this is what I'm hitting the Wayback
Machine to last June
right that it would turn into Wiggins
and a potential fourth overall selection
right because it's protected up to
number three for this coming draft you'd
say what I mean because that's basically
what they've turned this into right here
with the 2022 second-round pick
understood so yeah no I mean rich that's
the right way of looking at it and you
would say that's fine just as we said it
was fine they got D'Angelo Russell
because Durant was going to leave
regardless so it's a matter of getting
something instead of nothing now Wiggins
is coming with a big contract attached
and so they're you know anybody who's a
still a very you know pronounced skeptic
of Wiggins of which there are probably
many justifiably you might say uh that's
not the best use of an outgoing Kevin
Durant but the pic I think makes it more
palatable and again Wiggins is still
young enough that if you feel really
confident as an organization about your
player development skills your staff
your surrounding caste it's different
again I can't stress this enough because
we see it all the time in this league
but guys drafted high and he just
doesn't work out because all the
expectations are on him in one place and
he's you know guys have talent but they
don't all have the right mental makeup
to carry a franchise or they're better
off really in the NBA being a number two
or number three and it could still
blossom into an all-star zone number two
or number three
but with Wiggins really wasn't cut out
to be a number one for the Timberwolves
or a ko number one with towns it's we're
going to see I'm convinced of this much
we will see a much different version of
him with the Warriors and I think again
if you're losing Durant and what you got
was Wiggins still young enough with
potential and a number one pick that
could be pretty high in the lottery
that's not bad
Howard back here
the Rich Eisen show okay so tell me what
what the Rockettes are thinking with
their trade with the Rockettes getting
Covington yeah yeah Covington with
capella yes sir going what do you think
here yeah I mean it's really fascinating
because you know D'Antoni's always been
a fan of small ball and PJ Tucker has
been a great small ball Center but small
ball in this league these last several
years has mostly meant you know the
Warriors rolling out the death lineup
you know they start with Andrew Bogut or
they start with some other true center
playing the starting minutes and it's
not some point in a game they do you
know if they've unleashed a death line
up and they go small but with draymond
Green and the Rockets are basically
committing to like just a full time
version of this with PJ Tucker as the
undersized Center and I think they're
still as the last I would saw last I
heard scouring the market for a big for
the you know in case of emergency break
glass situations but I think they're
committed to the idea they're just going
to go small and they're gonna say well
you know whatever we give up defensively
two teams that have bigs will you know
will will more than make up for it the
other end because you're not going to be
able to keep up with us and we're going
to shoot a ton of threes
Covington like their defense the Rockets
defense has been pretty average at best
and Covington will help shore up the
defense they're going to be switchable
one through five
that has been their hallmark to to have
that kind of defense and we'll see how
it works out for them it's a really
interested in gambit I mean the heat
Grizzlies trade intriguing on both ends
here man I mean Iguodala being sent to
the heat we all know about his playoff
bonafide ease Jae Crowder to it looks
like Riley's getting some some veterans
of the may/june set to throw there in
Miami to make a run maybe at Yanis
Howard
well they definitely have their eyes on
Yanis as a lot of teams around the
league do in 2021 but in the near term
and I think the near term is the more
important more important part of this
because they went from a team that you
know okay we're good and we're plucky
and oh look we signed Jimmy Butler to
fringe contender in the East - oh now
they're definitely a contender I mean I
think no I by the way that was what I
meant making a run at Yanis I should
have said the buck I like right now I
mean like making a run thrown no no like
to make a run here I mean at 34 and 16
it's you know no one's gonna raise the
white flag it just seems like he's
trying to get him now is what I'm saying
and beat him yes yes yes no they're
trying to beat him now and sign them
down the road sorry I misinterpreted no
it's my fault for saying it that way the
Bucks the Bucks record-wise have been
ahead of the pack I think structurally
though if you just look across the
contenders in the East I don't know that
any team on talent alone is far and away
better than the other and I that's what
all due respect to the Bucks on their
record and what they've achieved and I
think that the heat as one of those
teams along with Toronto along with
Boston Philly although Philly's weird I
just put them off the side for the
moment but these other teams that are in
the running they're all really based
around one ultimate star you know Jimmy
Butler Pascal siakam Boston's more of a
collective and and the Bucks IV honest
so if you're the the heat and your
strength has been Butler plus a bunch of
really really good players and great
ball movement passing defense and you
add Iguodala in there and you bring in
Jae Crowder
and we'll see what else they can pull
off I mean I also along the way I mean
this is the wizardry of Pat Riley and
Andy ellisburg they pawned off their two
problem children in Jay James Johnson
and and dion Waiters in this deal
that's incredible few more minutes left
with Bleacher Report's howard back here
on the Rich Eisen show as we're talking
right now the Knicks are playing the
lake
and Clippers off of one another from
Marcus Morris and hoping that maybe
Kuzma is involved in the trade from the
Lakers or Moe Harkless and others from
the Clippers while at the same time
they're reaching into the ranks of CAA
up on the avenue of the stars in Century
City to snag a new team president
walk me through what's going on with the
Knicks howard boys so many gears moving
with the Knicks right now it's that they
moved this quickly to create a new front
office out of thin air just days after
firing Steve mills or removing them from
that position it's busy and frankly so
Leon rose will come in from CAA we'll
see who else he brings with him we'll
see what kind of new front up structure
they create on the fly here in the
meantime Scott Perry who was the GM
under mills is I would presume to be the
one doing all this because Lea Rose has
to divest all of his CAA interest he
still represents a bunch of guy he can't
be the president right this minute it's
not possible it's not legal so this is
Scott Perry and the rest of the folks
who were left over there trying to play
the Clippers and Lakers off of each
other in the Marcus Morris sweepstakes I
think you know one of those things is
going to happen and it's the right move
you know they signed all these guys last
summer it was a really bizarre you know
Plan B after they missed KD and Kyrie
and the rest the Stars and it always
made more sense once this season went
off course as it predictably did that
you would move on those veterans and try
to get value for them so if they can get
a first-round pick and Moe Harkless or
whoever it's going to be they've got to
do it then they should be they should be
ripping out everything to the studs like
every everybody on that roster almost
should be available right now because
there's not a lot to build with and you
just you really just need to keep trying
to set yourself up for the future so
that when Leon rose and his group come
in they've got more tools to work with
so from what you're telling me the
Knicks are making a major front office
maneuver and remaking the entire
structure one would imagine underneath
James Dolan just as there is a trade
deadline happening with
general manager that we are assuming is
either the choice of Leon rose or not
and this was after the inevitable
cratering of a first half of a season
because Kevin Durant and Kyrie didn't
arrive even though James Dolan said they
he was very confident they would is that
did I did I pretty much sum that all up
accurately Howard that's pretty much it
yeah okay
so it looks like while we're talking
right now it has been confirmed that
Morris is gonna be a clipper and we'll
see what happens there does this does
that change anything you think with
what's going on atop the Western
Conference here Howard that they're
clippers are now loaded for bear to try
and deny the Lakers what what they're
hoping for right now well I think that
one this was a more predictable outcome
because the Clippers had I think a
little bit more maneuverability to make
a deal the Lakers didn't have a lot to
offer especially if they don't want to
give up Kuzma and I thought you know the
it's a great move for the Clippers
those two teams are neck and neck is
Marcus Morris going to be the difference
between the Clippers or the Lakers
winning the West
I don't know but he's a tough player he
can shoot the three he can defend
multiple positions he's a guy you can
certainly throw at LeBron James now if
you're the Clippers you could throw
Kawhi at LeBron James you can throw Paul
George at LeBron James you can you can
do a number of things now if you're the
Clippers defensively you've got great
versatility not just you know against
LeBron obviously but the rest of playoff
field as well he's a great addition and
he's an upgrade for them and great
another great move by the Clipper
front-office which has been doing great
work you know really for the last two
years how I appreciate the time
thanks much we'll chat with you down the
line appreciate it
thank you rich always plays it right
back at you at Howard Beck on Twitter
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app